as we've been showing you the pandemic
has affected some communities harder
than
others maria viral reports from a
hard-hit hospital near the
southern border in texas where the
latino population
has suffered immense loss she arrived as
staff were beginning vaccinations
these vaccines are a small sign of hope
for frontline workers along the south
texas border
i'm so excited that it's here even with
a little fear
but a heart of gratitude
because it's so needed nurse
practitioner melissa gonzalez says
over 20 of her family members were
diagnosed with coronavirus
including her mother and aunt who died
from the disease
i've dived into work a little bit more
because i don't want to deal with
i have no mom
to go home too hidalgo county where
gonzalez
lives and works is around 92 percent
latino
according to the cdc roughly one in four
people who contract coronavirus are
hispanic
a study found they are
disproportionately at risk because of
factors like
lack of access to health care
multi-generational households
and a higher proportion of front-line
jobs this is going to save lives
many of them dhr health chief medical
officer robert martinez was one of the
first to take the vaccine
to ease people's skepticism we can show
the community that we're serious about
this because we know it's going to work
for the most part and save our community
a lot of pain
pain that nurse brittany paloma's
parents maria palomo and robert salinas
know
firsthand after just starting her job in
march
she was just 27 when she died in
november
i take my baby away from us
she was too young it wasn't her time
the palomo family is skeptical of the
vaccine but they say their daughter a
nurse would have wanted them to take it
today
the dedicated staff here at dhr pharmacy
staff right now
they are getting ready for the day it is
early here but they are ready to go you
can see they have three different
areas set up the vaccines are here they
are thawed out
they did yesterday a 12 hour shift there
was a line
around this building more than sixteen
hundred doses were given out they wanna
do the same again today but they remind
everybody do not let your guard down
right now
you still have to social distance and
you still gotta wear these masks
such important work and that's an
important story maria thank you very
much we appreciate